hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es mal eine
ankündigung von mir denn bald ist ja der
fastenmonat ramadan und da gibt es
wieder eine tolle reihe von uns bzw von
mir und haben sie hinter der kamera
und letztes jahr war es auch schon so
dass wir alle zwei tage ein neues rezept
gepostet haben und das kam so gut bei
euch an dass wir das auf jeden fall
fortführen werden mit ganz vielen tollen
neuen rezepten die euch das
fastenbrechen erleichtern sollen oder
vielleicht auch das frühstück ein paar
ideen für das frühstück und ich bin ganz
gespannt was ihr zu sagen habt mit
dieser reihe ändert sich auch etwas
anderes grundlegendes und zwar dass ich
jetzt vor der kamera direkt zu euch
spreche dafür habe ich meine wand
tapeziert hoffe es gefällt euch
irgendwie doch total passend weil es
orientalisch aussieht habe ich genau
mein geschmack mir gefällt es ganz gut
ich hoffe dass euch auch gefällt und ich
freue mich schon sehr darauf was ich
noch anmerken möchte ist das meer über
instagram auch ganz viele nicht-muslime
geschrieben haben
aber dann nicht fassen dass die gesagt
haben ich freue mich trotzdem auf den
ramadan reihe weil es immer wieder
inspirierend ist diese orientalische
gerichte zu sehen und auszuprobieren
ich freue mich auf euer feedback und
sagt bis zum nächsten mal tschüss